the air-spitting bangs of stun grenades
and the accurate smell of tear gas in
Tel Aviv
as rival groups from Israel's Eritrean
Community engaged in pitched battles
with rocks and clubs local people
described it as being like a war zone
the Catalyst for the violence and events
organized by the Eritrean Embassy to
celebrate the government of President
Isaiah's afworki and 30 years of
Eritrean Independence but eritreans who
have fled the country because of
Africa's authoritarian rule are outraged
why did we run from our country because
of this dictator why they are
celebrating her today why did the Israel
police give them a permit to celebrate
for this dictator we are against this
why am I here seeking Asylum
what is happening here is that dictator
wants to do a festival we are against
this Festival we are not living a good
life he is creating chaos and problems
for us we are against him we don't want
a festival to take place here the result
was Fury and Chaos police say they'd
consulted both sides in the Eritrean
community in recent days and were not
expecting this intensity of violence
that assessment now looks seriously
questionable
casualties were taken to several
different medical centers among the
wounded several described as seriously
hurt and some critically ill dozens of
police officers were also injured
there's been political reaction to
members of Israel's right-wing coalition
government blaming the high court for
what they said were decisions which
facilitated the violence opposition
members of the knesset rapidly pointing
the finger of blame back at the
government the demonstrators were
finally dispersed after several hours
leaving behind blood-stained Pavements
and smashed up shop windows and a sense
of simmering tension
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera occupied East
Jerusalem
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera